I wrote a book from 1984 to 1999 called
maps of meaning and a lot of the things
I talked about come out of all the
reading I did during that period cuz I
was reading an insane amount and
thinking really non-stop 16 hours a day
like the only way I could stop myself
from thinking was to go workout with
weights I couldn't shut off my my
concern with the issues that I was
dealing with and I was spending about
three hours a day writing and I did that
every day for 15 years and that was the
consequence that was the book and the
writing also helped a tremendous amount
because it helps clarify your thinking
writing you know because actually you're
smarter when you write because you can
externalize your thoughts and then you
can you can use your working memory to
analyze what you've written instead of
remembering the thought and so you're
externalize in your memory you can
analyze what you thought you can refine
it you can reorder it you can edit like
mad with a word processor which is also
a very new thing to editing is very
difficult if you have to do that with
pen and paper with a typewriter it's
like forget it you you get your first
draft and that's it